madame la sénatrice merci de cette
question
qui fait écho à plusieurs questions qui
m'ont été posées et qui font écho au
rapport de la Cour des comptes alors
d'abord je voudrais nous inviter
collectivement à lire la totalité du
rapport de la Cour des comptes et pas se
limiter à la page 9 et aux deux recolles
recommandations qui sont faites ça
serait justice que le regard que
l'orange je vais en dire un mot le
travail qui a été fait par la Cour des
comptes deuxième élément là où on peut
avoir et c'est normal qu'on puisse avoir
un débat y compris avec la Cour des
comptes c'est sur l'équilibrage et le ce
qui est proposé par la Cour des comptes
au fond c'est une simple décroissance et
une décapitalisation qu'il faudrait
forcer pour répondre à des objectifs que
par ailleurs nous avons nécessité de
tenir qui sont des objectifs carbone
alors loin de moi l'idée d'abord de dire
que l'élevage ne doit pas prendre sa
part des efforts qu'il faut faire en
termes de décarbonation d'ailleurs ils
se sont mis sur ce chemin il y a des
travaux de recherche et d'innovation qui
posent qui portent par exemple sur
l'alimentation qui permettent de tenir
cette trajectoire loin de moi l'idée de
dire que la consommation était les
évolutions de consommation ne sont pas à
tenir compte depuis 20 ou 30 ans on sait
que structurellement il y a une baisse
de la consommation et que parfois on se
on va de vers la viande de la revient en
rouge vers la de Blanche donc tout ça
c'est des choses qu'il faut regarder en
lucidité mais en revanche il y a quelque
chose qui est choquant c'est de proposer
comme seul perspective à un éleveur ça
fait partie des deux recommandations
c'est finalement de ne plus être éleveur
et ça c'est quelque chose qui me
semble-t-il n'est pas acceptable d'abord
parce que maintenant ça n'est pas
acceptable et qu'est-ce que deuxièmement
sur ces territoires là en particulier
les bovins allaitants il n'y a pas
d'autres solutions que faire de
l'élevage ou rien et troisième élément
et d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes le dit
et ça j'invite à le regarder quand même
c'est comment on tient mieux compte des
autres services grand l'élevage que
celui d’abord de nous alimenter qui est
quand même un service important et on a
besoin je pense de réfléchir à ce que
sont les équilibres de viande et quel
est les matières de viande qu'on a
besoin de produire en France pour
répondre aux besoins de consommation
mais deuxièmement quelles sont les
aménités comme handicap apporte
l'élevage en particulier les haies le
maintien des paysages ouverts la lutte
contre les incendies de forêts le
maintien des prairies la préservation de
la biodiversité tout ça ça a de la
valeur et donc tout ça il faut il faut
en rendre compte il faut aussi en rendre
compte dans les soutiens financiers qui
sont apportés à l'élevage et donc nous
caricaturons pas les uns les autres on a
besoin d'avoir une trajectoire carbone
au niveau national mais on a besoin
aussi de respecter les éleveurs dans
leur travail et dans les différentes
utilités et à méditer qu'ils apportent à
la société française tout entière